petit cadeau de anujan
Si vous avez une excellente mémoire vous vous souvenez de ce que c'est Ancroma ?
Hein ce petit test de daltonisme que j'avais fait
Ce qui est cool c'est qu'à la suite de cette vidéo
Et euh, y'a eu déjà beaucoup de gens qui sont allés faire le test de daltonisme
sur le site.
Donc Ancroma a repéré qu'il y avait du mouvement
Ils ont trouvé ma vidéo et ils m'ont proposé
de m'envoyer des lunettes qui corrigent, en quelques sortes,
mon daltonisme.
Souvenez-vous, moi je suis Deutéranomal
parce que c'est le vert que je vois mal.
Et ce qui voient mal le rouge sont des Protanomal
Et aussi ce qui voient mal le bleu qui sont des Tritanomal
Ah ouais, c'est compliqué
Bref, y'a différentes lunettes selon votre type
de daltonisme.
Y'a aussi des daltoniens qui voient qu'une seule couleur
et le monde est hyper fade pour eux.
Et ces lunettes leurs permettent de voir un peu plus
comme les gens normaux.
Alors attention, ça corrige pas à 100%
euh, ta vision, c'est à dire que je vais pas voir 100%
comme quelqu'un qui n'est pas daltonien
Mais vu que moi en fait mon daltonisme est assez léger j'me demande
Si ça va vraiment modifier ma perception des couleurs
Et si c'est le cas je me demande ce que les gens normaux voient en fait
Parce que je... je pensais pas que...
C'était un vrai handicap en fait, j'avais pas calé que j'étais vraiment...
Daltonien, j'pensais qu'j'avais une petite défaillance mais pas qu'c'était...
Du daltonisme ! Ouais c'est naïf ouais ! Clairement !
right ! Pinpinpinpiiiiiin !
Je les ai ! Alors celles-ci c'est des lunettes d'extérieur.
C'est à dire qu'il faut les utiliser en extérieur
Quand il fait assez soleil. C'est le cas aujourd'hui on a de la chance
Alors il faut savoir que ça marche pour 4 personnes
Sur 5 et pas pour 100% des gens
Et il faut aussi savoir que quand je vais les mettre l'effet ne sera pas
Immédiat... Déjà j'aurais un style énorme
Ca ça sera immédiat par contre comme effet
Ca prendra entre 10 et 15 minutes et j'espère
Ne pas être la personne sur 5 chez qui ça marche pas
Putain ça me ferait chier... J'vais aller dehors et j'ai acheté tout simplement
Des fruits et des légumes de couleur !
hein, comme par exemple, une pomme ! Voilà !
Ou encore une tomate ! Parce que ce sont des objets dont tout le monde connait la couleur
et dont la couleur est assez pétante. Donc je pense que ça peut être un bon test !
Dernière info avant d'y allez parce que je trouve ça assez ouf
En faite les hommes ont un seul chromosome x vous le savez et les femmes en ont 2
Et en faite, c'est ce chromosome x qui est porteur du gène du daltonisme
Du coup y'a un mec sur 12 sur la planète qui est daltonien
Et une fille sur 200 qui l'est
Donc une fille vu qu'elle a 2 chromosomes x
Et ben si l'un est atteint - est porteur du gène pardon
Le deuxième, lui est safe et du coup, euh, bah il verra les couleurs normalement
Mais il arrive que les 2 soient porteurs, euh, du gène
Et du coup dans ce cas là bah, la fille est daltonienne
Donc rien qu'en France, on est à peu près 65 millions d'habitants
Ca fait qu'il y a 3 millions de daltoniens d'après les statistiques
Et j'suis persuadé qu'y'en a pleins qui le savent même pas
Voilà c'était le moment mathématique, c'était le moment statistiques
Il est temps d'aller essayer ça, je vais sur la terrasse
musique entraînante
Ok au lieu d'aller sur la terrasse on est allé dehors parce qu'il y a plus de truc à voir
J'sais pas pourquoi j'ai dit la terrasse j'suis débile
Attention première fois que je les mets c'est parti
Woooow
De fuck mec
Je sens que ma vision est en train de s'adapter c'est trop bizarre
C'est comme si y'avait un filtre rose
Peut être qu'elles sont un peu trop puissantes par rapport à.. à ma vision
C'est peut être pour ça qu'faut attendre 10/15 minutes
L'effet des couleurs est pas immédiat en revanche
L'effet du style, lui est immédiat
18h12
Dison qu'à 18h22 j'pense que je serai complètement habitué
Il s'est foutu de ma gueule, il m'a regardé en rigolant
Le mec se moque d'un handicapé quoi ...
mec j'ai l’impression de je voit juste mal le vert
mais j'ai l'impression que on a mis la
sa sur un logiciel de montage et qu'on a augmenter la saturation un peu
c'est trop bizarre
je te jure mec j'ai l'impression qu'on a vraiment pimpé la saturation
musiques entraînante
c'est ouf on vient de passer devant le rayon gel douche
et en faite j'ai bloqué parce que je tout est grave différent en fait
normalement ya des couleurs ou j’arrive à différencier mais la différence est moins flagrante en fait
genre ça ,ça
Mais j'ai l'impression que j'ai légèrement le truc
et il y en a qu'ils l'ont plus ou moins.
Je pense que les lunettes corriges pour les gens qu'ils l'ont assez fort.
C'est pour ça que je vois vraiment la différence
entre les truc, genre abuser, je sais pas.
On s'en fou, tu veux de l'eau, plus tôt Évian, plus tôt Hepar ?
Euh... Plutôt Vittel.
OK, va te faire enculer. Alors...
*musiques entraînante*
Sa fait actuellement... 13 minutes
que j'ai les lunettes.
J'ai trouvé une apli qui va me permettre de vous montrez
ce que je vois moi habituellement
car là je suis entrain de dire : "Je vois plus coloré !"
je pense qu'il y a plus intéressant comme vidéo
En gros, je vois beaucoup plus coloré, comme je vous l'ai dit j'ai l'impression
qu'il y a plus de contrastes et de saturations.
Mais il y a en a limite trop !
En faite, je pense que les lunettes corrigent le défaut de
de visions diverses que j'ai.
un peu trop fort pour moi, je dois avoir le problème mais pas
à ce point enfaite .
C'est comme même cool sa me permet de différencier le gris et le rose facilement.
Tout comme le rouge, le jaune et le orange
Au supermarché, il y avait un caddie rouget et un gamin avec un sac orange juste à côté.
Et ça m'a frappé la différence. Comme les gels douche j'arrive vraiment à bien différencier et tout
On va rentrer et on va essayer de regarder des fruits et des légumes voir si ça me parait un peu plus ouf